die türkei ist wichtig für deutschland
alt bundespräsident gauck brauchen
unterstützung erdogan
was die türkei leistet ist bemerkenswert
beim ersten durchscrollen der artikel
fällt auf ja tt berichtet oft über die
türkei viel über erdogan zu viel und zu
positiv sagen kritiker sie befürchten
trt deutsch könnte zum sprachrohr eines
autoritären präsidenten werden mit sitz
in berlin finanziert auch aus türkischen
steuern potenzielles publikum etwa drei
millionen deutsch türken und das klingt
dann so stell dir vor dein land ist seit
über 30 jahren mit terroristischen
angriffen konfrontiert
deine europäischen und westlichen
verbündeten verurteilen die angreifer
erkennen diese als terror-organisation
an und sichern die ihr ihre
unterstützung zu doch plötzlich taucht
eine neue größere und viel
weitreichendere bedrohung auf die dich
und deine starken verbündeten angreift
was macht nun einer deiner besten
verbündeten r bildet den verlängerten
arm seines erzfeindes aus und bewaffnet
diesen mit dem ziel den neuen bösewicht
zu bekämpfen und stationiert diesen in
seiner unmittelbaren nähe
nun ist klar warum die türkei verärgert
ist
das video soll die hintergründe der
türkischen militäroffensive in
nordsyrien erklären
kritiker sagen rechtfertigen ist das
narrativ ganz einfach eine klassische
inszenierung von erdogan das ist dem
sender schon sehr wichtig das merkt man
auch immer wieder an diversen
auseinandersetzungen an diverser daran
an diversen darstellung von konflikten
und krisen lennart hagemeyer ist politik
und kommunikationswissenschaftler an der
hochschule hannover hat sich intensiv
mit trt deutsch und dem türkischen
muttersender beschäftigt
die gefahr eines solchen senders in
deutschland liegt vor allem darin dass
immer weniger an die klassischen medien
glauben dass medien vertrauen bröckelt
weil einfach diese meinung die dort an
oder diese nachrichten die dort
angeboten werden
andere als illegitim darstellen andere
akteure als illegitim darstellen das
heißt wir haben weniger medien vertrauen
werden weniger vertrauen in
demokratische institutionen und vor
allem ein sich zurückziehen in
ad-hoc-kammer chefredakteur kahn l bier
posiert noch im dezember an der seite
von präsident erdogan weist die vorwürfe
der regierungs nähe aber zurück zieht
sich eher als opfer einer
schmutzkampagne
wir sind nicht ein sprachrohr oder wir
sind nicht die vertretung der türkei in
deutschland das sich deutsch-türken
grundsätzlich medien wie trt zuwenden
wundert soziologe aladin el maadani
nicht das interesse vieler es ist groß
und das spannende daran ist dass es
gerade in deutscher sprache immer größer
wird weil immer mehr türkeistämmige er
auf deutsch nachrichten verfolgen
könnten als in türkischer sprache
ob tt wirklich zum sprachrohr erdogans
in deutschland wird oder nicht zeigt
wohl erst gezahlt
das potenzial dieser plattform ist
jedenfalls riesig